Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Dr. Papers.
Today we are going to have a look at what
is new in the physics of hair in virtual worlds.
You see, this is a challenging problem where
these virtual characters are given fur or
other kinds of hair, and we have to simulate
their interactions via Coulomb-friction.
This is dry friction when two surfaces come
into contact.
Which typically arises when we have lots of
hair, and thus, lots of strand-strand interactions.
That happens a great deal whenever a wolf
is jumping or running around.
And when things start moving, these simulations
can get very, very messy.
This previous paper that we talked about earlier
can resolve such conflicts, and create beautiful,
realistic hair simulations.
However, this class of algorithms typically
takes forever to compute.
They are typically not even close to real
time.
However, NVIDIA has also done some research
on it, these algorithms typically run on your
graphics card, and are fast enough to be deployed
in real video games and other virtual worlds.
But wait, these can not resolve scenes that
are as detailed as the ones in the previous
paper.
With this, we have to resort to much simpler
models and fewer hair strands, many of which
typically move together.
To the best of my knowledge, they also haven’t
seen a lot of improvements over the last few
years.
So, are we done?
Is there no hope for quick and detailed hair
simulations?
Well, sometimes, all it takes is just one
person.
One scientist.
Yes, you are seeing correctly, this is a one-author
SIGGRAPH paper from NVIDIA on this exact topic,
so I am itching to look at it together.
And…whoa.
Now that is a next-generation hair simulation
right there!
It looks like almost every single hair strand
is simulated independently.
My goodness!
And as I am a light transport researcher by
trade, I have to note that I love how the
specular highlights are computed here.
And what you see here is the favorite pastime
of the computer graphics researcher.
And here.
Yes, this time I hope it will not get as painful
as with some of the previous papers.
But it looks like this character is getting
away by just getting its hair cut.
Very fun experiment indeed.
And now comes the bombshell: These models
have thousands of hair strands that are made
up of 120,000 points, that is incredible,
so now I feel that it’s appropriate to pop
the question.
So, it does all this how quickly exactly?
Well, hold on to your papers Fellow Scholars,
because it does all this in 17 milliseconds.
Yes, all this is happening in real time.
And these are not some run of the mill simulations
that we saw earlier.
No sir!
These are super detailed.
And if we pop the hood and look at the internal
workings of the algorithm, we see that most
of the time is spent with detecting and resolving
these collisions, and oh my goodness.
Are you seeing what I am seeing?
Oh yes, depending on the current state of
the hair, there is substantial variation between
the execution times of the algorithm.
That is big trouble!
Why?
Well, because if we are in any kind of virtual
world or we are playing a video game, we have
to make sure that every individual picture
is computed quickly and on time.
If one moment we have 10 frames per second,
and the next moment we have 60, what we get
is a jarring experience.
So, are we done?
Is this not going to make it?
Do not despair for a second, because most
of the time it runs so quickly, it only takes
a couple milliseconds, and sometimes not even
a millisecond.
So I think this one is going to do just fine
and hopefully will be implemented in the video
games of the future.
What a time to be alive!
But just one more quick question - is this
actually accurate?
Well, let’s have a closer look at these
two lines, and there we have our answer.
Now, I hear you saying, Dr. Papers, why are
you saying that there are two lines here,
I see only one!
And that is exactly the point.
The simulated results are so close to reality
that the measurements essentially overlap.
And all that in real time.
That is incredible.
And now you can see that the papers that we
discuss here are real, they get out of there
in the real world to be used in real products
by millions of people.
And sometimes, all this comes from the ingenuity
of one Fellow Scholar.
One scientist is all it takes to change everything.
Huge congratulations!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you
next time!